there's no question that some
philanthropists are effective and I hate
to say it but I would say that most are
not if you define effectiveness as
actually making a measurable difference
on the social problem that you care
about and the reason I believe is that
most philanthropists are thinking about
how do I give away money who should I
give money to how do I respond to the
request that come at me all the time and
they're not thinking about how do you
really solve a problem and when you
begin to think about actually solving a
problem and taking responsibility for
all the different elements that need to
be in place it's a very different
process I'll give you a couple examples
one is a small foundation in Atlanta
that we worked with called the Rockdale
foundation and in foundation terms
they're extremely small they give away
maybe half a million dollars a year and
they decided that they wanted to promote
microfinance in Palestinian territories
in Arab countries and back in 99 when
they started there were only about
40,000 microfinance borrowers in Arab
countries and they could have given to a
charity but instead they sort of SAT
back and said what would you need to
have as an infrastructure for a thriving
microfinance enterprise and they found
there's a lot of materials about how to
do microfinance none of them were in
Arabic so they hired translators to come
translate materials and they found there
was one small association of these
microfinance lenders but it didn't have
much capital people weren't aware of it
so they organized an international
conference and they provided technical
assistance to this organization and
there's a long list of things they did
themselves not just writing checks to a
charity and what's really striking is
when they last looked in 2007 so it was
about eight years after they started
there were three million Arab
microfinance borrowers there were
instead of about a dozen small lenders
there were now almost 70 microfinance
lenders active in these countries and
this little umbrella organization that
started with now had 18 major funders
behind it and had achieved real scale so
we really can solve social problems or
at least make a big difference on them
but only if we really tackle things in a
realistic way it's focused on solving
the problem not on giving away give
another example Tom Siebel in siebel
systems focused a few years ago on the
meth problem and he focused in on
Montana which had a very severe meth
problem and it was the fifth worst state
in the country in terms of Matthews and
it is it's a terrible drug it's highly
addictive and the primary users are 12
to 17 years old and it really can
destroy a life if someone begins to use
it in that age group and back in 2005
Tom did some surveys around teenagers in
Montana and he found that only about a
quarter of them were aware of the risk
and two-thirds of them had been offered
meth by a friend in the last six months
I mean it was just so prevalent and he
said you know Montana is a small media
market there's only a million people you
know what if we could really influence
how teenagers think about this and so he
hired j walter Thompson he heard
first-rate advertising agencies he did
lots of focus groups of the audience he
was trying to reach these teenagers and
he saturated the market 45,000
television commercials in a year I mean
his goal was that eighty percent of 12
to 17 year-old in Montana would have at
least three media impressions a week of
his anti meth campaign and in two years
meth usage dropped by half and when they
went back and surveyed again
ninety-three percent of kids in that age
group were aware of the risk
% said their friends would give them a
hard time if they ever tried meth they
changed the culture and again it there
wasn't a charity he gave to he figured
out how can i solve a problem and bring
enough resources to bear to really make
a difference